hi baby girl just want to wish you a
happy birthday
Jennifer Lopez just turned 50 guys yeah
freakin 50 it's my party naturally her
fiance Alex Rodriguez celebrated the
milestone birthday in a totally swoon
worthy way since we've been together you
have made me feel like every day is my
birthday the 43 year old former baseball
pro took to Instagram to do what he does
best gush over his fiance thank you for
your passion and your energy and your
inspiration and your endless pursuit to
be the best at everything that you do
you're simply the best partner like the
best daughter of the best mother the
best performer a rod shared this sweet
video montage set to Billy Joel's 1986
hit this is the time sharing pics of
their time together and with their
families which includes J Lo's 11-year
old twins with X Mark Anthony M en
Maximilian as well as Alex's two
daughters eleven-year-old Ella and 14
year old Natasha we love you your fans
love you your children love you and I
love you let's make this birthday
the mucho I'm not crying
you're crying no but really JLo is
crying it got me a little emotional the
singer was clearly moved by the post
blowing up her man's comment section to
write I'm crying I love our life I love
you so much thank you
my beautiful macho she also shared this
pic on her Instagram story writing love
of my life okay okay we get it
you guys are perfect I think because of
what he's done and performing on such a
big stage and you know and with the
Yankees all over the United States he he
understands my life in a way that nobody
else really has and and we come from
similar backgrounds and we just we
really have a special connection that
way but in case you guys missed the memo
a rod took it one step further posting
of videos from a post show backstage
celebration with his girl
[Applause]
[Music]
and that that is a birthday card that is
so tall
JLo can actually stand inside of it eg
recently caught up with JLo where she
dished about her big birthday plans so
what are you guys gonna do when your
actual birthday comes around it's July
well I'm my 24th the 27th I was Congress
they went closed the tour in Miami the
25th 26 and 27 right so I have off on my
birthday but then I have to do three
shows in a row in Miami and the last one
is on his birthday so we'll probably
have a party that night yeah and I head
off to Europe oh my god you're not doing
on your actual birthday there on my
birthday house Tommy would be there off
let me like lay here with my feet up
that would be the best birthday present
before I have to like kill three shows
in Miami well I'm still here feeling
fully shook by the fact that she is
freaking 50 what is your secret Jennifer
tell us of course I will be here to keep
you up to date on all things JLo so make
sure to keep it locked right here on et
until next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye
for now
[Music]